Follow lane focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
Okay.
So the most commonly spoken romance
languages are of Spanish,
Portuguese,
French,
Italian.
Um,
that was one more,
what was it?
Oh Micky.
Stop that.
What are you doing?
Okay.
Anyway,
so the romance language just came from
the Roman Empire,
the languages of Rome.
Um,
what was it again?
Oh,
Mickey.
Mickey,
what are you doing?
Give me that.
Okay.
Anyway,
so what was it?
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is the Romanian language
or lean borrow mueller in Romanian.
As you can see the word Romanian
contains the word Roman in it.
Why?
Because it developed from the language
of the Romans Latin to clarify Romanian
as a member of the romance language
family.
When speaking of romance languages,
Romanian tends to get overlooked and I'm
guilty of that myself.
Maybe it's because of its geographic
isolation from the other romance
languages.
You can see that the other major romance
languages are all spoken in western
Europe,
but Romanian has spoken in eastern
Europe and to separate it from the
others by the Belkins and parts of
central Europe,
Romania and as part of the Eastern
Romance Branch and there are other
languages of this branch which are
spoken by minorities throughout
southeastern Europe.
Notice that the names of these languages
contain the word Romanian.
These languages are all closely related
to Romania.
Sometimes the word Romania is used to
refer to all of these closely related
languages together and some eastern
romance speakers consider them to be
dialects of one language.
The language of Romania and Moldova is
sometimes referred to as Dayco Romania
to distinguish between it and the
others.
Dayco Romanian has the largest number of
speakers out of all of those languages
by far and at this video I'm basically
focusing on Dayco Romanian.
Romanian is spoken by a route 24 million
native speakers and around 4000002nd
language speakers.
It is the official language of Romania
where it is the mother tongue of around
93% of the people or around 18.6
million people as well as the official
language of Moldova.
We're at spoken by around 2.7
5 million people in Moldova.
The language is referred to as muddle
van by some people and as Romanian by
others.
Romanian is somewhat unique amongst the
romance languages because it developed
in close contact with other languages,
mainly the Slavic languages which have
influenced its pronunciation and
vocabulary.
The closest romance language to Romanian
is reportedly Italian,
which shares about 77% lexical
similarity with Romanian.
Compare that to 82% for Italian and
Spanish or 89% for Italian and French
history.
The people living in the area before the
arrival of the Romans were known as the
dations or Dutchy and Romanian day.
Shell was conquered by the Roman
military in one oh six ce and the
population adopted the Latin language
very quickly.
Exactly what happened is not clear.
Maybe the nation people simply adopted
the Latin language of their conquerors,
but it's also possible that the area was
flooded with Roman settlers who
intermarried with the local stations.
There's also the theory that the nation
language was already an Italian
language,
closely related to Latin.
What is clear is that the area became
very latinized.
Very quickly.
The Roman Empire withdrew its military
from Daysha and two 71 to two 72 ce,
but left behind a romanized Latin
speaking population.
The next few centuries are fairly
mysterious,
but the local dialects of Latin
gradually evolved and sometime before
the ninth century Prodo Romanian,
the ancestor of Romanian and all the
eastern Romance Languages,
Oh rose,
there are different opinions about
whether protal Romanian developed from
the vulgar Latin spoken by the romanized
station population or from a variety of
vulgar Latin spoken by people south of
the Danube river,
who later migrated to the North Slavic
influence.
Notice again that Romanian is surrounded
by mostly Slavic languages.
That's because of the migration of
Slavic speakers into the area.
Between the seventh and ninth century CE
contact with Slavic speakers had an
influence on eastern romance,
particularly in vocabulary and
pronunciation but also in grammar and
other areas.
It's fucked that many Slavic speakers
adopted the local romance dialect,
but because it was their second language
they spoke it with an accent and they
continue to use certain Slavic words
that felt natural for them to keep
using.
Old Church.
Slavonic must have also had an influence
on Romanian because it was the
administrative language until the 16th
century and the liturgical language
until the 17th century.
It's hard to know exactly how Romanian
developed during the Middle Ages because
there are no existing Romanian texts
from before the 16th century.
The earliest Romanian text is niac shoes
letter,
which dates to 1521 it was written with
the Cyrillic alphabet which was used to
write Romanian until the 19th century.
This is an obvious result of the Slavic
influence on the language,
the modern period.
It's beyond the scope of this video to
go into detail about the history of
Romania and the governments that ruled
over its different parts.
What's important for us to remember is
that despite changing borders and
governments,
there remained an ethnic and linguistic
group that considered themselves
Romanian with a growing sense of
Romanian national identity efforts to
standardize the Romanian language began
in the 18th century.
The first Romanian grammar was published
in 1780 in the 18 hundreds Romanian
linguists made a concerted effort to
read Latin guys the language and remove
Slavic and other influences from the
language.
And interestingly in replacing a lot of
the non romance vocabulary,
they drew words not only from Latin but
also from Italian that especially from
French,
when Romania became an independent
country in 1878 it's official language
became Romanian.
It's borders changed several times
during the 20th century,
while Moldova spent much of the 20th
century under Soviet rule as it gained
independence,
Moldova made Moldova in it's language.
The consensus is that Romanian and
Moldovan are a single language just with
some regional variation.
The standard written language is exactly
the same for both Romanian and Moldovan.
So how did this romance language survive
in this area when most others didn't
survive?
Well,
nobody really knows.
But as I said before,
the area known as Daysha became
thoroughly latinized probably more than
other areas in the region.
So whereas in other areas,
the Latin influence faded after the
departure of the Roman empire in Daysha
that Latin influenced did not fade.
There are also various theories about
the people fending off invaders better
than others or that the geography of
their land insulated them from being
overrun that assimilated.
For example,
some say that the Carpathian mountains
provided a barrier for attack from the
north and east or provided refuge and
strategic high ground above invaders.
But again,
nobody really knows.
So what is Romanian like?
Well,
since Romanian is a romance language
that developed from Latin,
it's obviously quite similar to French,
Spanish,
Italian,
and other romance languages,
but it's also been influenced by other
languages,
particularly at the Slavic language,
just because of its position in the
Balkan [inaudible] wound.
The balkins prop wound is an area in
which the various languages have
mutually influenced each other,
including romance languages,
Slavic languages,
Greek and Albanian.
It has also been influenced by other
nearby languages,
like Hungarian vocabulary.
The majority of Romanian vocabulary is
of Latin and romance origin based on one
study,
63% of Romanian vocabulary is romance,
while 11.5%
is slavic with other vocabulary coming
from Turkish,
Greek,
Hungarian,
and German.
But if we focus on the most common 2,500
words in Romanian,
the percentage of romance vocabulary is
around 76% and slavic around 15% let's
look at some sentences and examine their
vocabulary.
[inaudible] is [inaudible].
This means I know the history of Europe,
very well word for word,
it's I know history,
the Europe's very well.
All of these words are romance words.
Cornell risk means I know or I'm
familiar with and it's like Conosco in
Italian or Juco ne in French you studier
means history and it's like sturdier in
Italian or east La.
In French it would ropey means European
and is like a,
it will pale in Italian or google pay on
in French four out of the day means very
in Romanian and is related to the word
meaning strong in Italian photo tay and
in French fall.
So here it means very and it's not used
that way in Italian or French being the
means,
well like the Italian word Bennett and
like the French word beyond another
example,
I'm spoiled,
Machina,
foot up probe limit and Fatah casy.
This means I washed the car in front of
the house without any problems.
Word for word,
it's myself.
I wash car,
the without problems in face houses the
means me or myself like me in Italian or
in French it's the indirect object
pronouns which is used here because the
verbus reflexive but means wash in the
first person singular.
This word developed from vulgar Latin x
bed Levada and it's like the Portuguese
word pedal.
Nevada meaning to wash machina means car
and a similar to Makena in Italian and
like Makina in Spanish which means
machine or engine.
Flooded means without and comes from
Latin thought us like 40 in Italian
which means outside put it all blemish
is also a romance word coming from Latin
[inaudible] which ultimately came from
ancient Greek.
It means in and comes from Latin and
ultimately goes all the way back to
Prodo,
Indo European Fidessa I means face or
front and comes from vulgar Latin.
Fuck Ya.
It's similar to fuck in Italian and fuss
and French.
[inaudible] means house like Kazaa in
Italian and Casa in Spanish.
Another example today with the or prima
does boil.
This means we must stop the war word for
word.
It's must subjunctive stop war that Abe
we means have to and as a slavic lone
word comes from Latin C and at this
sentence indicates the subjunctive mood
or putting means stop and as a Slavic
Lone word that does bullying means war
and is also a slavic lone word.
Many commonly used Romanian words are of
Slavic origin.
A few more examples are but yet then
friend Iub to love Uplit d to Pay
[inaudible] to wake up a go to see to
find.
So as you can see the majority of
Romanian vocabulary is romance
vocabulary but Slavic vocabulary is also
quite evident.
We'd order.
The word order of Romanian is very
similar to other romance languages with
one particular difference that we'll
notice.
[inaudible]
is [inaudible],
CONOSCO,
Storia,
[inaudible] Molto Bene.
The keywords in these sentences are all
in the same order.
What's different is that the Romanian
sentence has no standalone definite
article or preposition for of that's
because while other romance languages no
longer have Cayston declensions for
nouns and adjectives like Latin did,
Romanian does have them.
Well,
it has three case declensions for
announce languages that don't have case.
Declensions often use prepositions
instead to indicate the same information
in the sentence it [inaudible] is in the
genitive case,
meaning of Europe or Europe's.
The most basic form of the noun is
actually [inaudible] with an a,
but the eye at the end is a definite
article and the he indicates genitive
case because the genitive case indicates
possession.
We don't need a preposition meaning of
like an Italian.
As for the definite article in Romanian,
it comes at the end of the word and
works together with the case.
Declension in the word you sturdier the
Aa shows that the word is definite.
So we don't need a definite article
before the word Noun cases.
Let's look a noun in Romanian and see
how it changes form depending on its
case,
meaning it's role in the sentence.
The Noun is but a but which means man
first in the singular indefinite
nominative and accusative wound,
but a buck genitive and dative Uber
Bucks.
Definite but a bottle,
but a bottle and in the plural
indefinite initiative,
but a butts.
Who Norbert Bucks?
Definite.
But Betsy.
But Betsy Lord,
here are a couple of examples of case
declensions in context focusing on the
word,
but uh,
but,
but a bottle,
all machinery.
This sentence means the man bought a car
word for word Ed's man has bought a car.
The form of the word for the man,
but about tool is in the nominative case
because it's the subject.
So we use the definite declension for
nominative case that we saw before.
Another example.
Blanchet my Sheena [inaudible].
This sentence means I like the man's car
word for word,
it's myself or to me like car,
the man,
the possessive,
the form of the word for the man is in
the genitive case because it's showing
possession.
So we use the definite declension for
genitive data that we saw before the ul
coming after the word,
but a but represents the definite
article.
If the definite article is followed by
Ui that indicates genitive or dative,
but a but is a masculine.
No Feminine Nouns and neuter nouns take
different case declensions.
Yes,
Romanian has maintained neuter gender
unlike the other romance languages.
Let's look at one more Romanian sentence
together and see what we notice.
The ankles of amy [inaudible] up picnic.
The sentence means due to the rainy
weather,
we couldn't go to the picnic word for
word.
It's from cause weather rainy.
No,
we have could go to picnic.
The is a contraction of debt plus in
which both come from Latin cows is a
romance word that was borrowed from
French.
Cozy that amy means weather and as a
slavic lone word,
it's a feminine now than the base form
is that I may,
but in this sentence it's in the date of
case represented by this ending I plus
the definite article I thrill USC means
rainy and comes from Latin [inaudible].
This adjective is also declined to agree
with the singular feminine date of case.
Now the day me no means no and comes
from Latin known,
um,
is the first person plural form of the
verb for to have similar to another
romance languages.
Past actions can be expressed by using
the auxiliary verb to have along with
the past participle means could and it's
the past participle of up with death
which comes from Latin [inaudible] they
saw together,
um,
and put to it,
I mean could or were able to message.
It means go and comes from the Latin
medidata meaning to dip or to plunge.
But in Romania,
Romanian it means to go.
La is a preposition,
meaning to and comes from the Latin you
luck and picnic means picnic and comes
from the French word picnic.
If you speak a romance language or if
you've ever studied a romance language,
then you'll probably notice a lot of
similarities with Romania,
but you may have to look a little closer
to notice those similarities.
Romanian clearly developed in a somewhat
different direction from other romance
languages and even though it was re
latinized,
it still feels more slavic in some ways
and the way words are articulated in the
way words are formed and in some details
of the grammar.
That's what makes Romanian interesting
and unique amongst the romance
languages.
It's development in geographic isolation
from the others and it's contact with
neighboring languages.
So the question of the day for speakers
of Romanian,
how similar to you think Romanian is to
the other romance languages like Italian
and for speakers of other romance
languages.
How similar or different to you think
Romanian is from your language and what
stands out to you as the biggest
difference?
Let us know in the comments down below.
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter and instagram.
And again,
I would like to say thank you to all of
my patrion supporters,
especially these ones right here on the
screen for their monthly pledges.
Thank you very much and have a nice.